Ahora que hemos establecido
nuestras ecuaciones,
veamos si  podemos contestar
algunas preguntas interesantes,
y a manera de calentamiento voy
a hacer lo que hice en el video pasado,
pero lo voy a hacer con las ecuaciones,
las ecuaciones son representaciones matemáticas
de lo mismo que tenemos
acá arriba con palabras.
A manera de calentamiento
calculemos entonces bajo el plan básico
¿cual sería el costo de asistir
a tres sesiones en un mes dado?
Bien, tenemos aquí nuestra ecuación el costo
total va a ser igual a 20 más 20 más 8
por el número de sesiones,
el número de sesiones es 3,
sustituimos el 3 en vez de la "s"
y va a ser 8 por 3,
nuestro costo total para 3 sesiones
sería 20 más 8 por 3, 20 más 24 que es 44.
Vamos a ponerlo acá arriba,
déjame borrar esto primero...
Así es que por 3 sesiones pagaré 44 dólares.
Ahora, hagamos lo mismo para el plan de prueba,
¿cuánto nos costará asistir a tres sesiones?
Aquí el cálculo es más directo,
el costo total...
el costo total "c" es igual a 12,
12 por el número de sesiones,
en este caso el número de sesiones es 3,
sustituimos en vez de la "s" 3,
sería 12 por 3,
el costo total es 36 dólares.
Vamos a ponerlo acá arriba,
borro primero esto...
el costo total de asistir a 3 sesiones
bajo el plan de prueba es 36 dólares.
Pero también podemos responder a preguntas
más interesantes con estas ecuaciones,
como por ejemplo,
¿a cuántas... a cuántas sesiones...
a cuántas sesiones puedo asistir... a cuántas
sesiones puedo asistir por,
digamos que tengo... mmm... digamos... 54 dólares?
54 dólares...
ya tengo mi presupuesto,
en base a lo que gano,
pude determinar
que lo que tengo para ponerme en forma con acondicionamiento físico son 54 dólares
y quiero saber de acuerdo a cada plan
¿a cuántas sesiones puedo asistir
pagando esa cantidad?
Empecemos con el plan de prueba,
¿a cuántas sesiones puedo asistir por 54 dólares?
Y supongamos que este es un estudio especial
donde puedes inclusive asistir a media sesión,
por media sesión bajo este plan, pagarías 6 dólares,
por 1/4 de sesión te cobrarían 3 dólares,
se llevaría un control de la fracción
de sesiones a las que asistes,
no siempre necesitarías
tomar sesiones enteras,
podrías asistir a dos y media
y te cobrarían de acuerdo a eso.
Habiendo considerado eso podemos preguntarnos,
bajo el plan de prueba
a cuantas sesiones puedo asistir con 54 dólares, pensemos en esto un momento,
ahora mi costo "c" es 54 dólares,
el costo mensual "c" es 54 dólares,
54 es igual a 12...
12 por el número de las sesiones a las que puedo asistir, 12 por "s".
Ahora que he establecido esta ecuación
para contestar a esta pregunta,
debo de encontrar cual es el número de sesiones "s"
que cumple con esta ecuación,
Ahora que "s" es la incógnita,
¿cuál es el valor de "s" que
multiplicado por 12 nos da igual a 54?
Y aquí fíjate,
si dejamos a la "s" sola del lado derecho,
vamos a obtener la solución pues "s"
va a ser igual a algún valor
y para dejar sola a la "s" del lado derecho,
vamos a dividir este lado derecho entre 12,
"12s" dividido entre 12,
me va a dar "s",
me va a dar el número de sesiones,
pero si tengo un signo de igual
y no quiero que se altere esa igualdad,
no puedo únicamente dividir el lado derecho entre 12, también necesito dividir entre 12 el lado izquierdo,
si esto es igual a eso
para que se mantenga esta igualdad
tengo que hacer lo mismo
a ambos lados de la igualdad.
Así es que del lado derecho nos queda tan solo la "s"
y del lado izquierdo nos queda 54 entre 12...
a ver veamos cuantas veces cabe 12 entre 54,
lo voy a hacer por aquí arriba,
12 que divide a 54,
veamos 54 entre 12 es a 4,
4 por 12 = 48, lo restamos,
54 menos 48 es 6,
es decir 54 entre 12 me da 4
y me sobran 6,
vamos a escribirlo aquí,
54 entre 12 es igual a 4 enteros 6/12,
lo cual es igual a 4 enteros 1/2,
"s", el número de sesiones
a las que puedo asistir son 4 y 1/2,
el número de sesiones
a las que puedo asistir con 54 dólares
bajo el plan de prueba
son 4 sesiones y media,
si este fuera un estudio que dijera
no puedes asistir a fracciones de sesiones,
en ese caso podría afirmar que lo más que puedo asistir son a 4 sesiones para no salirme del presupuesto,
pero hemos aceptado que
se pueden asistir a sesiones fraccionadas,
así es que puedo asistir
a 4 sesiones y media.
Ahora contestemos esa misma pregunta
para el plan básico.
Bajo el plan básico,
¿a cuántas sesiones puedo asistir por 54 dólares?
Bien, de nueva cuenta, éste va a ser nuestro
costo total para ese mes.
Así es que aquí tenemos que "c" es igual a 54,
lo cual es igual a 20 más 8
por el número de sesiones...
20 más 8 por el número de sesiones.
Y de nueva cuenta quiero dejar solo a las
sesiones del lado derecho,
para que pueda decir bueno,
sesiones es igual a algo,
obtener así el número de sesiones
a las que puedo asistir,
pero tengo este 20 aquí y este 8 aquí
y tengo que pensar cómo deshacerme de ellos.
Lo primero que voy a ver es cómo quitar
este 20 del lado derecho
y eso va a ser algo que tengo
que hacer para toda la ecuación,
lo más fácil para esto es restar 20 del lado derecho,
pero si resto 20 del lado derecho,
tengo que restar 20 también del lado izquierdo
para mantener la igualdad,
¿y qué me resulta de esto?
Bueno, del lado izquierdo 54 menos 20 es 34
y el lado derecho, bueno,
hemos hecho todo esto para deshacernos del 20
y solo nos va a quedar "8s", así es que,
8 veces el número de sesiones es igual a 34,
para que 8 veces el número de sesiones
más 20 sea igual a 54,
puedes sumar 20 a ambos lados
de esta última ecuación,
para obtener la original.
Ya casi hemos terminado, nos falta tan solo
despejar la "s" de aquí y como puedes suponer,
lo más fácil es dividir el lado derecho entre 8
y si dividimos el lado derecho entre 8,
también tenemos que dividir
el lado izquierdo entre 8,
¿y entonces cuál es ese número de sesiones
a las cuales podemos asistir?
Del lado derecho los 8 se cancelan y obtenemos
que el número de sesiones es igual a 34 entre 8
y 34 dividido entre 8 es igual a veamos...
8 cabe 4 veces en 34 y nos quedan 2 octavos,
lo cual es igual a 4 enteros 1/4.
Así es que puedo asistir a 4 sesiones y 1/4,
bajo el plan básico,
así que suponiendo que puedo asistir
a sesiones fraccionadas, por 54 dólares,
¿cuál es el plan que me permite
asistir a más sesiones?
¿el plan básico o el plan de prueba?
Lo que hemos encontrado al resolver nuestras
ecuaciones es que por 54 dólares,
puedo asistir ligeramente a más sesiones
bajo el plan de prueba.